[Music]
marketing for the now marketing for the
now marketing for the now
marketing for the now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hi everyone and welcome to vaynerx
presents marketing for the now
how are you doing gary i'm doing
extremely well how are you
i'm good it's our 17th episode and i
have to say after a day like yesterday
i'm feeling pretty fine that makes me
happy
yes it is beautiful in sunshine and i am
extremely excited about our first show
of the year
we've got an awesome lineup um it's our
first episode of 2021
and we are going to focus on one
question
as you know what does the modern media
plan look like
in 2021 so we're going to kick things
off with andrea brimmer andrea is the
chief marketing and public relations
officer at ally financial where she
leads a team of 150
disruptive marketers since then um
allied brand has doubled in value every
year since
she launched uh the new promise in 2016.
and so over those three years they've
been celebrating ally's promise
do it right welcome andrea thank you
andrea appreciate being here hey gary
how are you with so many andreas i know
right i've never been around so many
andreas at once
so andrew first of all how's your new
year going how you feeling what's
cooking
i am feeling good gary i feel uh you
know yesterday was a just a good day for
our country i feel like a good good
amount of peace and um
yeah rock and roll the new year and
ready to rock and roll
so let's get right into it because you
know we have a lot of entrepreneurs we
have a lot of
fortune 500 companies so we're trying to
break this down a little bit but i think
let's real and keep i love the dog in
the background don't worry about that
it's perfect exactly how i want it
all right what does the modern media
plan
look like and and actually i'm going to
take one second to help the viewers
the coms planning the planning like
where are you going to put your money
to make the thing that you want to
happen for entrepreneurs you're kind of
doing that on the wheel for big codes
andrea will go into that in a second you
know there's a lot you know you hire a
media agency they plan
you know but i think the landscape andre
i think we can agree
is changing so quickly and kind of when
you watch
mad men years ago the tv department just
gets stood up right it's tv
print outdoor radio go to sleep
right then there's this thing called
internet but then
my life's work realizes that's like
saying oxygen there's a million things
in there
when you hear the question that we're
doing today what is the modern media
plan look like
what does what does that come across to
you as
and one last time before you answer i
see you all in the comments michael lynn
charlotte nicole jeff hodge i see on all
the different platforms please hit
twitter hard with your questions and
observations using
marketing for the now and we will try to
incorporate you into the show
andrea the floor is yours thanks gary
you know i mean the way that we think
about it
is um i could really boil it into kind
of three words that are
guiding the way that i think about it
and the way our our team's thinking
about it alley
dynamic disruptive and culturally astute
and
when i think about dynamic it's the
point
that it is ever changing like
you take last year as an example nobody
would have ever expected the
unavailability of original production
the migration of audiences to new
platforms
the importance of things like
gamification
versus um you know linear tv
um and and a marketer that's not
prepared
for that you know that constantly
shifting atmosphere and just sets it and
forgets it
is really missing where audiences are
going so that idea of dynamic is
as really critically important um
do you feel like you have that in place
like when you think i mean i think this
is you know
and you know this this is a community
especially today's question
gonna help a lot of the community that
you sit in these incredibly important
cmos and operators
you know i have a lot of compassion
right i know this ecosystem now after
you know a decade and a half the media
planning capabilities structure and and
to be frank the objectives of the you
know media agencies for their own margin
and i have empathy for their businesses
i'm in that business
though we come from a different angle
really challenge flexibility live
a lot of those companies have major
deals with platforms and networks that
they have to
you know i made a promise to nbc i'm
going to make sure that ally runs a
little bit more commercial
and i'm going to just i mean that's real
talk now and i want to get to the real
crux do you feel
incredible about the flexibility or is
that
a 500 pound gorilla that's hard to move
just so people can get a read of how
challenging this actually it sounds it
sounds easy for all the small business
and entrepreneurs that are listening
that's all they know
it's actually stunningly hard for big
companies like yours yeah it is i mean i
think the advantage is that we've always
had this scrappy challenger mentality
and we've always um we've always
projected that ethos and we've tried to
reflect it in terms of the way that
we've planned media i mean look
i'd be lying to you if i didn't say that
there's always going to be
this compendium of planning that will
have a level of consistency right you
you're going to buy
your you're going to buy your broadcast
with a level of consistency you're going
to go into the upfronts and that's what
you're going to have and
and you're going to plan against certain
kinds of media but
you have to remain flexible and in a
perpetual state of motion
because you not only can you not predict
what's going to happen throughout the
year
um you also can't predict where
audiences are going to go and i just
take last year as a great example
you know we we always keep a pot of
money for optimization people like my
cfo crazy sometimes where she's like why
do you have all this fluidity in your
plan i need more predictability
um but we have to have it because you
have to go
where your consumers are going one of
the big places we moved last year was
into gaming
home and we created an island on animal
crossing
we did a ton around gamification that
wasn't anything that we could have seen
at the beginning of the year and if we
didn't have the ability to push for that
flexibility
and i think to your point gary one of
the things that we changed in terms of
our
the way that we measure our agency
partners especially media companies our
media agency
is around creativity and media and that
becomes
part of the you know the kpis that drive
them and i think that's where you get
that tension
between that long-term plan and i've got
to be creative because i've got
more to gain if i bring that creativity
these are these are shotgun interviews
so we have three minutes
andrea when i say to you what channel
has your attention
either has already been incorporated
into your media plan
or is brewing in your mind as a leader
and will then think about okay
let's let's really try to test this year
so it's a bigger part of our 2022.
is there any platforms and this could be
in any [ __ ] it doesn't have to be the
internet like is there anything brewing
in that brilliant mind that has you that
has you like
huh look what's going on over at
clubhouse or hey i think print is back
baby like like is there anything
brewing in your mind you know what's the
most interesting medium to me right now
honestly i mean you there's all the
obvious ones but outdoor
um we have done some really interesting
things
in outdoor and there's some incredible
um
creativity that's happening there and um
i think it gives you an opportunity to
have a big space are the are the prices
way down since people are in
like when i hear outdoor i mean the
amount of
travel people like the macro travel is
collapsed and so bill you know i think
of like how many people are not on the
road that saw billboards
that are now just not on the road has
the pricing become super attractive in
the habit
i don't even think about outdoor and
just that like i think about digital
outdoor i think about over the holidays
we projected
the 20 best moments of the year on
buildings around the country
i mean points still taken though you
know i assume common sense
driving people are just in their homes
we have a global pandemic
has are the prices adjusting or or a
little bit but you'd be
you'd be surprised at the interaction
people just want to get out of their
house even if they're just walking
around
um so it's an interesting medium and
we've done so but real quick because
this is i'm fascinated by this
on a good i mean if everything went
phenomenal
you'd have to expect on the greatest day
ever you're going to get 50
of as many people that would have saw
those things on the building let's say
in 2018
my my curiosity not even anything else
is
you know that thought that thought like
you can't you know i agree people want
to get out of their house but like
i live in manhattan there's a lot more
people in door and i look at everything
you know like i'm just
i think that's an interesting take yeah
i mean i think uh
i think about it in terms of um
as we start to plan coming out of this
pandemic and the
creativity that's there and um
the new things that you can do with the
medium that have never been available to
you before and the ability to put the
brand on a big stage
um you know everybody's rushing to the
same things right now
gamification digital you know
those social platforms etc um but as we
get into the spring and we kind of get
in get out from under this pandemic
um you know people that are taking
chances on those because you know
actually we ran out of time this is such
a pleasure
already but it's great to see you
continued success
thanks gary see ya thanks andrea
next we have molly batten vice president
of global brand marketing for delta
airlines
molly leads global corporate brand
strategy and management at delta
where she and her team are responsible
for portfolio marketing
agency management cross-promotion
planning and media among many
other things welcome molly thank you
thanks for
thanks for having me hey gary how are
you i'm well molly how have you been
i'm doing all right thanks good well
listen i mean
there are very few industries that have
been more affected
than yours during this global pandemic
so
hey how's the company doing how are you
doing it must be super challenging and i
obviously because we have some mutual
friends i recall kind of pinging you
when you first got the gig and so
you must have only been in place for a
little over a year or somewhere in that
range
before this all hits so before we even
get into
and i'm actually this this is the one
i'm probably most excited about because
i'd be dying to know how you're thinking
about media planning
with i mean wow what a challenging thing
you know i'm pretty good at intuition
and guessing but this one's out of my
realm
even like when does it come back um why
don't you start with that what's the
opening rant to that energy
yeah no gary it's been a fascinating
year yeah i think it was last year at
ces we were
trying to connect um because i know you
had done a lot of work with turner where
i was before
and a lot of help um as we were
launching brands and shows so
um it is great to see you again but um
it has been
a wild ride so i've been at delta for a
little over a year so i've seen
our best day ever last year profit
sharing day february 14th
and to kind of the worst day ever so
from the top to the bottom and we just
saw the
the bottom fallout as many across the
industry in the travel industry did
um in march and then just continued
decline and
i will say it's been um a fascinating
learning process as we have had to
rework
and reinvent and re and innovate the
airline from the inside out
everything that we do um by putting kind
of our people and our customers
front and center from how we sanitize
and clean every flight before every
flight
how we you know are still blocking the
middle seat to make sure that our
customers feel safe and comfortable when
they travel
um to partnerships with the mayo clinic
and lysol
um i know more about air filtration now
than i ever would have thought i would
have um you know and just the airflow on
the airplane so it's been
you know we've moved from really
creating demand and talking about travel
inspiration
um to really having to educate um
our our customers now travel is very
different than it was
last year um and we know that as people
are coming back whether it's your first
time or you've been back many times
there's more and different information
that you need now and that is really
affecting how we think about media
planning um
into next year because and even i'm
sorry to interrupt and even more
i would argue not importantly but
equally as importantly the back to the
creative messaging right
absolutely yeah and so we you know
really headline is we've moved from
broad-based kind of brand messaging
to really audience first planning and
messaging because we have such a segment
and you have plenty of awareness i mean
there's not a person on this right now
that does not know what delt is
right so it's it's really about you know
we we elevate and we talk what our brand
is about or we lead with our values our
mission is no one better connects the
world
but right now we have as you look across
the spectrum of
the audiences we've got you know folks
who are not really ready to travel yet
so we have to have messaging that can
connect with them of when you're ready
we're here for you and that travel
inspiration
to those that are hesitant and thinking
about it so how do we connect with them
with targeted messages to let them know
all the different things that we're
doing
to keep you safe when you travel um and
educate them on what travels like
to the people who are now traveling and
how do we make sure that they're feeling
good
and connected and we keep pulling them
back in so it's really a
a very different messaging strategy that
has led to a very different media
strategy
um and focusing on those audiences and
then identifying the right channels to
hit them
um and i apologize real quick jason
says stop interrupting gary jesus i just
want to remind everybody these are
10-minute meetings
i'm desperately trying to get as much
information out to everybody
these are my homies and friends and so i
apologize i get it
but i just want to jump into jason's
comment and get a little more out of
molly for example
any new platforms where the media is
going because of this initiative like is
this do you have
monies going into whether it's a tick
tock or a linkedin or pre-roll youtube
or ott
a hulu like any new any interesting
takes there
you know i don't know so much new but
what we've seen is the
um the increase in the impact of our
social channels
um this past year has been critical it's
been a way for us to engage with our
customers um leverage influencers um
and really get our story across um and
my social team has just completely
stepped up and is really using it to
inspire our travelers so we see stories
about the
you know um the the the flight attendant
who took the time
to take care of the passenger these
inspirational heartwarming stories about
our people
stories about um travel inspiration
because there's so much pent-up demand
and we think that this revenge spending
is going to come back
in full force hopefully next summer as
this vaccine
um continues to be distributed so hold
on molly real quick
next did you just say this coming summer
okay so
because you know it's funny i think
you're making an interesting point i
think all of us
somewhere in the summer of last year
said oh man
like the ones that were really being
honest were like oh we're gonna come
back next summer this is wow
oh my god i thought it was gonna be two
weeks i would argue that
and i i have empathy and compassion for
this there's some realization of like
wait a minute
we're not gonna be as back to normal
like 2019
even this summer and that actually gets
me the next point do you have any
um insights do you believe that in 24
months well let's say we're
vaccinated out we're kind of over the
hump is it your anticipation
that a high percentage of people on the
plane are going to wear masks
even when we're back to normal do we get
china vacationed
out like do you believe that the u.s
from your perspective
like i have been really thinking about
this i'm like wow will i ever take a
flight again in my life
where there's nobody wearing a mask and
my answer to myself was no
and not only no i'm like man i bet you
it's 25 of
the fl the flight is going to be there
thoughts on that
yeah no gary i mean it's hard to say
right i think we're going to be seeing
mass
um compliance for a while even through
the
vaccine we know it's important beyond um
even as we
continue to vaccinate the country um you
know we know from guidance from mayo
clinic and our partners that masks are
an essential
piece of kind of stopping the spread so
i think they're going to be here for a
while in terms of how long they're going
to be with us
i can't really speculate but i agree
with you i do think there's going to be
percentages of people that just feel
more comfortable when they travel and
it's not even
even past the pandemic it's it's the
person sneezing across away from you
and that mass gives you some protection
so yeah
as to what level i don't know but i i
think there will be
something that will carry through
new platforms i i think i'm excited to
ask people think things that are
starting to brew in your head of like
emerging media platforms because i think
everybody who's watching
entrepreneurs small businesses and
fortune 50s level and fortune 500s
can get value out of this question any
new platforms
or ones that they don't have to be new
but they've crossed over for you let's
say
ott you're like oh wow i'm going to take
some of my tv money
your turner form exactly like you
understand that that landscape oh i see
some real value in the targeting of ott
or i'm genuinely excited about the
passive consumption of voice so this
spotify ad product
anything in your mind as a lead
strategist to where the media planning
goes
anything anything starting to brew yeah
you know we're looking at a lot of
different things you know again
really understanding where our audiences
are and how we can deliver against it
you know i think there's a lot of
interesting things going on in the
podcast space
um as people have more time and are
staying at home and kind of consuming
that type of content i do agree i think
streaming we have seen huge shifts
in the ways people are consuming media
as people are home longer their
viewing habits are changing so how do we
capture that attentive audience
you know i think i think as andrew was
saying i do think out of home is
interesting
um you can do a lot more with it than we
used to be able to
and we look at it not only on the paid
assets but how are we using our own
assets um and our earned placements
in a different way so that we're really
using them to educate
along the entire travel journey because
we've got you know we're really lucky
once we get you in the plane we have a
great in-flight video
um you know connected cabin is kind of
our vision
and so how can we make that inside the
cabin feeling
um feel like your living room and
there's opportunity there to kind of
talk to our loyal
um and current customers and reinforce
our messaging and our branding and our
values
so um we're kind of thinking about it
through the entire travel journey
and i think there's a lot of interesting
things out there and the new ways to
connect right
so moving beyond your traditional just
um straight spot and how do we create
more
interactive ways um for our cus for our
customers to kind of interact with us
and we've been doing a lot in social
um around gaming and questions and
quizzes
as well as kind of asking the experts so
we open up
so that people could ask the questions
that are on their mind and we get the
right experts um
to answer them so playing around with
instagram stories and
so it just there's a lot of um a lot of
opportunity for creativity i think
within media for next year
and i know there's need to continue to
be agile and be able to move as
budgets change and we're figuring out
what this world looks like and
and travelers kind of expand or collapse
hopefully more expand
um but having that that creativity i
think is going to be key
to helping us continue to break through
and so um you know we're we're really
looking at different ways that
it's a two-way conversation i love that
mall we're out of time
have a great year good luck i know it's
a challenging one but
we're excited to see what you come up
with great gary thanks so much hope to
see you on a flight soon
you will next we welcome
rupen desai global cmo at dole
a company that believes everyone should
have equal access to nutrition and
health
delivered in a positive and sustainable
way and he joins us from
singapore i might add also co-founded
tc 28 to help organizations thrive in
the conscience
economy and is a board member at female
founders dedicated to gender equality in
entrepreneurship
and leadership welcome rupen thank you
thank you andrea
thank you for having me gary rubin is it
past midnight
it is i'm very impressed with you sir no
but a lot of my life
is spent with teams in la so this allows
me the morning
as they've been waking up so i've i've
i've been in calls
from 6 a.m uh la time unfortunately for
the teams in l.a right
right listen it's a global world
and even more now actually rupen before
we get into the core question
i assume that the zoomification of our
society through kovid
has been a real blessing for you given
the separation
as people become more comfortable to
this you know i'll give you an example
if you emailed me 24 months ago and said
gary i want to work with vaynermedia
my brain goes to this is a real
opportunity i need to get my ass to
singapore
that is a four-day mission three-day
mission even the extreme way i travel
the fact that the business etiquette now
allows for me and you to have that
meeting like this for two hours
is really quite powerful no it is
it is i mean my my girls haven't seen as
much of me as they have in the last nine
months
okay i remember my last flight uh being
early march
yes same obviously on a given day they
love it on a given day i'm sure
uh remember from the family you don't
there's more yeah yeah
and i'm sure it's both ways i think
it's it's been a learning process for a
lot of us as well because
we all come from the school of thought
that physical presence physical meanings
absolutely matter and we got to make the
trudge and we got to do the fly
and while all of that is true i think
the last nine or ten months have shown
us
it's not probably as true as we would
have all liked to believe
yeah i think that's right i think that's
exactly right let's get to the core
question
you know what is your take on the modern
2021
you know media plan what does it look
like you know how how do companies
need to adjust and where should they be
shifting their monies or doubling down
which platforms
which genres speak to you or the
consumers you're trying to
reach so i think we need to start from
the fact that the currencies that we're
chasing
with our consumers have changed
considerably over the years
i mean we're talking about earning
attention and earning
trust with our consumers and we
sometimes forget that the key part of
that is
the earning part so most platforms have
got better at interrupting i mean we can
interrupt better we can interrupt faster
we can interrupt personalize we can
interrupt uh
whichever area you were
into and that's got better and better
and while i don't
underestimate the importance of on uh of
interrupting
there's a huge part of earning the
attention
earning the trust i mean i the way i i
try and define it is like
is dropping into a dinner that you're
having on a friday night
uninvited okay and the moment i start
talking about how i clean whiter than
the whitest how my
uh molecules bigger than your molecule
on a friday night in your house
it's going to be a very short
conversation
so unless i'm purposeful unless i'm
interesting
unless i have something to offer of
value unless
i i have a joke to crack
unless i make you laugh and and
it's it's uh there's no way i'm getting
invited
again or you're ordering a second bottle
of wine
that's right so let's talk about that do
you then believe
that the creative is a more important
variable than the media plan
it's a tango isn't it no i don't think
yeah well it is a dance and it's a dance
that actually takes a cue
from the other and he rolls along the
process ruben
actually i'm sorry to interrupt do you
believe that
the biggest hole in marketing today is
that the creative industry has struggled
to make
contextual creative to all these
distribution channels
i think we have got so excited
by the by the potential of data
by the potential of personalization by
the potential
that we have forgotten that the art is
still in the conversation the art is
still in the earning attention the
art so while all of those vehicles are
extremely important
and the modern media plan is it's a
it's it's a cacophony that needs to be
orchestrated into some form of semblance
of music
i think the starting point will have to
be
how do i stop interrupting and if i
can't
how do i at least make it worthwhile for
you as i interrupt
your life and we do this you see the
the weird part gary about this is we're
all in meetings and we're
having this conversation it's wonderful
and we step out to check out on facebook
and we're behaving exactly the opposite
i mean
you know you're not going to go through
this screen right now and kiss your
beautiful head you understand that
reuben
no but listen this is my you know this
is my existence this is why vaynermedia
exists i mean
i just don't understand how people spend
all their money
on things that they know no no
is not true or do not hold the creative
contextual
to the platform they they just know that
consumers don't respond to it
but they there is so much incredible
comfort
in doing things in the past or to
conform
to a reporting mechanism internally you
got it
the the reporting that justifies the
behavior that advances one's career and
i'm
i'm empathetic to that you know you're
trying to pay a mortgage
you're taking care of your family so if
the internal mmm
is based on grp's or impression like i
understand
but it is a very intriguing moment in
marketing because of that
yeah we're we're agreeing we're agreeing
and i think the
other big challenge for marketing and
i'm going to completely sidetrack from
the
the con the the question is
is the impact brands can have on people
communities societies
beyond just the profit bid
okay and and the three p's have always
had a fight with each other
particularly over the last few decades
people prosperity and the planet i mean
one usually comes at the cost of the
other
but i think if nothing else kobe
needs to teach us uh that one thing that
the three
need to live they're so interdependent
they they can't come at the cost of each
other we have to find business models
in marketing in business in how we
communicate
but at a larger society where where
planet
and communities planet and people are
interdependent with prosperity and
thrive together
i think that's exactly right i i i think
that people
make up excuses in business there used
to be a time when we used
child labor and the excuses were
well how are we going to be able to get
this done if we take all the children
out of
the workforce we figured it out this
notion that we can't do good at
both sides of the equation is a silly
lazy
answer my friend and look i look into
the eyes of
i have two young girls uh seven and four
and i know that everything i am
potentially doing
is going to leave behind a worser planet
and a worser off world today
but if there's nothing else i do in life
as a dad
i need to use whatever i do at work
obviously to make sure their education
gets paid off if they do
learn some stuff but but
the amount of influence we have as
brands and all the people on this
on on this the amount of influence we
have
has to has to make a difference beyond
next quarter's romy which is still stuck
somewhere in the 1960s of calculation
100 my friend this was quite enjoyable
i'll be in singapore soon and we're
going to have to have dinner because you
excited me here today take care of
yourself
thank you so much thank you andrea for
having us thank you rupen
next up we welcome andrea zong mensky
cmo of kfc us
andrea leads marketing advertising media
and consumer insights as well as the
brand's digital initiatives
driving sales overnight and brand over
time
prior to joining kfc andrea served many
marketing roles at png welcome andrea
hi gary how are you i'm well andre how
are you
i'm fantastic it's so good to see you
happy new year same to you
um let's get right into it yeah you know
you've got such a progressive brand
um you know some of the things you've
been the the gaming council
console thing you did like there's some
really cool stuff you're doing
as you walk it you're welcome you
deserve it what as you walk into
2021 given all the conditions trying to
figure out the timing of covid
delivery all the dynamics you're
thinking as a qsr
oh by the way i'm mentioning a lot of
acronyms here vaynerx world please get
into the comments in all these
communities and break down what mmm and
qsr
quick service restaurant by the way on
that one or all the other things that
i'm
saying here there's a lot of chatter in
the community so let's get some
management going
and value to the community or anybody
who's watching look out for that and
answer
andrea what uh what do you think about
from a media plan who's getting more of
your money this year compared to last
year is that tick-tock is that facebook
is that
television is that print uh what's
brewing like
you know how are you thinking about
creative into that what's the for one
one
yeah so i mean i think there's a few
things the first thing is like okay just
like
we've had to learn to be flexible just
like everybody else right
i mean we had to change everything in
our brand in four days because
customers needed us to like cook them
buckets of comfort food
right um but from a media perspective
what we're really
digging in on and what i think the real
magic of this kind of modern media plan
is really how we play across um across
those channels
right people are overwhelmed they're
flocking to places that don't have
advertising
right or limited advertising and we've
got a
aka aka the incredible growth of netflix
that doesn't have commercials
right right exactly i'm sure kfc has a
extremely strong tv execution but if
every day
somebody's not watching bravo or espn
what do you like
i mean you know where i sit on this we
know each other a little bit i mean i
think that's hurting big brands
tremendously i think they're throwing
good money
and then that nobody's listening to yeah
and we got and
and we have to think about the attention
that we do get
we have to treat it as really precious
right
i mean and so we're trying to make sure
that everything we put out there
is number one authentic and insightful
right like
which is more important to customers
than ever right but like i know who you
are
you're consistent with that and you
really get me and you really understand
me
and then with that is be making sure
that we're doing things that are useful
that we're creating content and
experiences that people actually want to
be part of
um and that is actually useful um in
their lives
and then native across native across
platforms i know gary you and i have
talked about this
like no more matching luggage right that
has to be
a thing of the past right um and so
we're trying to like use each platform
for
what it's best at like we don't want to
just go out and shout at every moment
buy kfc buy a kfc buy kfc um
there's some places that are really good
for that like our performance media that
we're doing
but there are other places where we need
to to be useful and authentic in other
ways
um we've gotta you know think about how
each of those elements built up
right each channel each element is
building up into
the way kfc as a brand shows up in total
in people's
lives like all those touch points should
not do the same thing
they have to build up to tell a holistic
story and then i know you guys just
talked about this but the power of
creativity
is never been more important we got to
think about how the messaging fits
across each of those platforms
and the truth is data has never been
more important either
but an algorithm can't do this for us
yeah i mean the data the data
that does it the data sets you up to say
something
so good you're informed but if you still
say something that's not interesting
you're not interested yeah something
that's not interesting something that's
not authentic something that's not
useful right like an example where we
did this recently you were talking about
some of the things we've done
and this came together really powerfully
for us was this lifetime movie we did in
december
um which was a 15-minute mini movie on
lifetime we co-created it with lifetime
um called recipe for seduction mario
lopez was colonel sanders with a
you know he's an up-and-coming chef with
a secret recipe and a dream
super authentic to our brand also super
authentic
lifetime like if you had a chance to
watch it like we played up the kernel in
a secret recipe but in a story that had
every element twist and turn you'd have
from a lifetime movie
but the thing that that the reason this
blew up
and people just got so excited about it
we got billions of impressions
was that it was really useful like back
you know even now but at the end of the
year like people just needed like good
old-fashioned escapism
um to like be able to get away and we
were able to provide that as a brand
now it's not that we weren't still
trying to find a way to sell fried
chicken
we had an uber eats promotion that was
dinner and a movie that once you got
down the funnel and you got onto some of
those platforms that are closer where
someone's maybe closer to
wanting to buy that fried chicken then
we're then we are telling them like hey
you can go get this ubereats promotion
and get
delivered and watch the movie to not
interrupt but philip smoke said
we need practical talk not overviews of
what big brands are doing so let's
let's play with this entrepreneur's
point of view from a tactical standpoint
you know there's a lot of people
watching right now that might have one
unit instead of the many that you have
when people think about actually getting
people to your point to buy
delivery you know when you think about
that lower funnel
yeah right because they're not because
philip can't buy a super bowl spot like
you can
right but what can people where are you
seeing
good performance to get people's intent
to buy
on one of these platforms because on an
uber eats whether your kfc
or your luigi's single you know meatball
shop
in columbus ohio there's a
democratization there what are you
seeing in the lower funnel attention
brand game
because i'm seeing a lot more brand work
in the lower funnel not just two for one
and things that nature anything stand
out for you when i go that narrow
no i mean i think that is where the data
really comes in
right and that is where you the
algorithms can work really hard
for you right you've got to have the
right offer and the right messaging you
need all kinds of a b testing to figure
out what's going to be more powerful
but that's where you really understand
what is my audience
that i'm going after and let the data
guide that audience and then what we're
finding is
those channels also depend greatly on
the audience we might go one place to
sell buckets of chicken to families
because at 4 30
at night i've realized i have no idea
what the heck i'm gonna
feed my family for dinner tonight so i'm
gonna serve them up a bucket promotion
and that's that audience and that might
do really well at 4 30 on a news channel
right
um but but then i also have my lunch
crew
right of like people that are like um
you know workers that need to go and
grab some lunch
and they really just need a big abundant
eat um for lunch and that might be
better served up
on facebook um because they're checking
their news feed before they go on their
lunch and figure you know when they get
to their lunch break and they are trying
to decide where to go
so it really is i think audience
specific and data driven
the chicken sandwich worse i mean this
has been a
american phenomenon you know any any
any cool thinking around that or are
there any media channels that have over
indexed uh in that game we are
well gary we are we've just announced uh
this month we just announced our
um entry college i'm aware into into the
into those chicken sandwich wars and so
we're building those plans um
as we as we speak yeah absolutely
but it is i will tell you like chicken
sandwiches have never been more popular
than they ever
ever it truly feels like we're in that
moment of american consumer transition
to the chicken sandwich becoming the
staple more so than the burger
yeah i mean it's very interesting it is
we're just seeing
a big draw to comfort food like people
you know if you just think about what
what people are experiencing their in
their lives
like even before covid by the way but
then that just put it on steroids and
everything else that has happened
like there is something that happens to
your brain um
like i think ida gardner said in her
most recent book like
you can feel um you can feel sad or
depressed before you eat comfort food
you can feel sad or depressed after you
eat comfort food but when you're eating
comfort food or that delicious fried
chicken sandwich that we have like
handcrafted
it's almost impossible in your brain to
feel sad
so i think chicken the chicken sandwich
wars are really
happening because of that a true
consumer need
um and want for um for comfort food so
even as we think about being useful
there is a use
even for even for that that comfort food
i appreciate you i hope you have a great
year it's great to see you thanks gary
take care have fun
next up mandy rossi vice president
head of marketing for the kroger company
mandy leads
marketing across kroger's 120 billion
dollar business
that spans 22 retail banners 2 800
physical stores and a seamless ecom
platform her team includes brand
strategy planning performance marketing
media
and kroger's internal creative agency
prior to joining kroger
mandy spent 14 years at p g welcome
mandy
hi thanks for having me hey mandy hi
i like your painting ah thank you
um happy new year and let's just get
right into
the core which is how was how is one of
the
largest leading supermarket retailers in
the country
thinking about marketing you know from a
media planning standpoint like for your
from your standpoint when i say what
does the modern
media plan look like in 2021 the real
question there is
is you got the lower funnel you got the
mid funnel you got the upper funnel aka
you know social media ott you got
television you
you know as a supermarket direct mail
and coupon there's a lot going on
in your world 120 billion sounds like a
big big big big girl number so
is there anything because of the covid
situation and or the modern
consumer shifts is there anything
getting a bigger piece of the pie or
anything any interesting insight
uh that you can share for the people
that are thinking about this yeah
lots has changed i think covet obviously
in
the grocery retail business and all
things food as andrea talked about too
it is a big shift right everybody's
eating at home
far more than they did before people
aren't out driving around
the way you think about whether you want
to go to a store or not
and the implications on e-commerce has
just been massive this year
um really accelerating the innovation in
some positive ways
as well you know the challenge we have
is exactly what you laid out we have all
the things right
uh we can send coupons personalized for
you directly to your house
or you can access them in our app all
the way to like the typical topo funnel
stuff
and we have a ton of data and in many
ways that's very useful
but the challenge is having it all be
connected and integrated
as we think about the data that we have
so in an average month we have about 11
million people
who are coming through our doors and
then if you think about that on an
annual basis it's a big number so we
have a lot of data
and it can be easy to get in the details
of that and try to measure everything
and we do measure a lot of things to
help it drive
our choices but some of it is like back
to basics right now when everything
feels
a little bit frenetic is really stepping
back
to who are the key customers that we
need to be relevant to and what do they
actually
need and why are we uniquely suited to
help them
uh and i think really coming back to
those brass tacks of
the needs people have which in the food
space actually haven't changed that much
they
they just get amplified yeah i mean i
would assume sort of interrupt i would
assume a lot more people are cooking at
home
which means they're going to choose you
as the infrastructure for that versus
going to a restaurant
that that must have some interesting
shifts and i think the other thing that
if people aren't very educated about
this marketplace the margins that you
play with are so small
food goes bad like it's a the
supermarket industry the reason they
become
the companies have become so big is you
need scale to really make it work
because it's a very challenging business
you got it and then like imagine now
being the marketer or managing the media
budget in a very margin tight
environment
each dollar needs to work really hard um
and that's where i think we just have to
be very focused on
who are the customers that we need to
win with what do they need right now and
how is this context
impacting all of those food jobs that
they have
and then really build a plan um looking
across that whole content ecosystem
to think about when do those moments
happen and how are they different for
you for me
at eight o'clock today at four o'clock
today at midnight
to really have a detailed plan but in
some ways
the plan is so big you can't control it
right so i don't see everything that
goes out it would be literally
impossible of course you have people
yeah that's why you have to build a
great team totally and be
crystal crystal clear on the audiences
the needs we're trying to meet and what
our business objectives are and sort of
the intersection of those things because
then
you can kind of set up the machine to go
off and deliver those things but if
we're not clear at the start
then you have total chaos because we
have so much data you can optimize a
channel
all day long if you like to but it won't
necessarily get us where we need to go
in the total picture if it's not in
service of a common objective
speaking of target audiences phil smoke
again says gary bring on a marketer to
help the little guys grow
and showcase their tactics big brands
have big budgets and most of your
viewers are working on the come up
philip i would say back to the way i
think everybody should be thinking
grocers and you brother
is as you are aware i put out 50 to 70
pieces of content a day
and 90 i would argue 79 to 90 of that
actually is for smbs and entrepreneurs
more than half the viewers of this right
now are corporate fortune 5000
individuals or marketers the comments
are normally where
more of the entrepreneurs are but the
consumption of this so philip it's it's
funny the question is so right right i
could have so much empathy marketing for
the now is absolutely
a fortune 500 ecosystem i do think when
you think about the dynamics that come
from these big brands
there are takeaways to your point but on
the micro stuff
that's what i'm doing on a daily daily
basis so for others thinking like philip
i just wanted to address that
back to you mandy any any new platforms
part of your media mix this year
we have shifted i don't know if there's
anything that is totally new
gaming probably would be the one um that
we want to get into this year that we've
not been in
um but it's a big shift of where we've
been right
grocery retail um has not always been
the most innovative from a media point
of view and we do need to reach a lot of
people
but i think we've been over invested for
too long
in some very traditional places where
frankly people just aren't engaging to
all the things um the people before me
said in the point she made um so really
thinking about the place is frankly
where i can use the data more i know the
roi is
significantly higher as long as we get
the content right
to kind of fit that context um
let's talk about that that ego system
you know facebook
instagram tick tock google youtube any
anything kind of that you're excited to
dig deeper into or actually even a more
interesting question
anything that you were able to take
advantage of maybe some of the found
time
in covid life that allowed you to become
a little bit more of a practitioner or
detail oriented back to your point
your way up here one of the things that
was a really interesting observation for
me is like ooh
my combos are getting better because i'm
in the dirt mandy back to phillips point
earlier
because of my brand and what i do i'm so
in the trenches
that there's a there's a level of
practitionership that i bring in the
agency fortune 500 ecosystem that's
quite different than the
industry i'm in i was excited to see a
lot of marketers
take advantage of kovid to get more in
the trenches
look under the hood because they found
back time of travel and things that
nature
where did you have that luxury or was
there too much going on or did you have
anything
like that that kind of said oh wait a
minute i didn't realize how good this
was working or
this is interesting did anything stand
out when i go that narrow
uh branded social for sure um
and we had a gift in a way there was a
lot of immediate stuff we had to get out
but
there was a lot of stuff that also got
turned off when you think about the
weekly promotional stuff that we get a
lot of word out on
got turned off in april and may and we
were able to reinvest into some places
we wanted to do more and i will say
branded
social uh as we've gotten better at the
content matching the platform
frankly we've i think done better with
our influencer strategy which
food is by the way a pretty fun space
for
um and especially when people are
cooking at home and looking for ideas
and all that it's been a really fun
playground
uh to be in and as we really tighten the
lens to be more about
food inspiration having some fun with it
getting tighter
frankly getting more diverse in our
influencer mix has been a very big focus
for us this year
um you know and as we would all expect
that works
um people want to see people who look
like them they want to see a diverse
representation that's very important
go figure right is twitch part of the
media spend because gaming's in or is it
more about doing
influencer work or or is it more on the
content side distributed
in different platforms um so we're
working through it now i can't share all
of it i will say it won't be twitch
uh because they're owned by a competitor
um
which creates some challenges um
there but also on some of the streaming
platforms that creates um
just some places where i'm not gonna go
right now i think that's fair with that
said
it's great to see you continued success
and we'll talk soon
thank you good to see you good to see
you
next aaron north joins us as the cmo of
ultra and mint mobile the fastest
growing brand in wireless
aaron has been a tour de force when it
comes to bringing
fresh thinking and disruptive behaviors
to both brands
and he's received multiple can lions
addies and effies over his career
welcome aaron thank you hi gary what's
up buddy
what's up is you've got me fired up with
that basketball hoop back there like i'm
jonesing
oh man because you know world champs
baby listen i'm very happy i own an
obnoxious amount of lebron james rookie
cards and i need him to capture a couple
more rings you don't happen to have the
actual basketball near you do you
uh i've got basketballs in my garage
yeah okay because i
you i think i i i want to see around the
room because i hope you're not dodging
it because i was going to make you take
a shot it was going to be a big moment
here
anyway mint such a interesting
challenger brand doing some really
creative stuff be
let's interstitial some of that
creativity but the core question
the media dollars yeah you know any big
shifts for you in 2021
off of the back of what we've seen lower
mid or upper funnel
any new things in digital as have you
added tick tock have you taken away
facebook have you added print have you
taken it away give us a lay of how y'all
are thinking about it yeah
well i mean awesome by the way so far
all the speakers and
i can talk to the small brand because
we're small we're growing like crazy but
we are small and i think
you know what's important for us is that
we're a direct consumer brand so you're
going to
think and see a lot of the performance
marketing tactics
but we we run different man we do a
different game
so i believe there are a couple of media
principles that aren't being applied
and as the cmo it's my job to make sure
we're thinking about the broader
business
not just a single tactic of performance
and the thing i think a lot of people
are missing
missing today is risk i don't think
people are putting enough risk into
their media plans
so i take our media budget and i take 10
of that and i put it into the unproven
the
unknown the untested and those don't
always have to be digital tactics as
well they don't have to be performance
tactics
i was reviewing what we did this last
year and we did some crazy stuff that
just
brands weren't doing like when the
pandemic hit on
friday the 13th stay at home order comes
in california
we immediately started pulling down our
media spend
but we can because we have a performance
media plan where we can turn
down television immediately we can turn
down digital immediately so we did that
and we didn't take that money and keep
it we reapplied it back to our consumer
base by giving them
free data upgrades right so that's a
choice we made
it was risky because it stopped the
influx of new customers but it took care
of existing
and i think that was a risk because it
was unproven but it saved our asses man
like our
churn dropped dramatically because we
were taking
such good care of our customers and
we've inserted new things we're doing
things
i'm sorry interrupt just for everybody
here farming versus hunting right
i think a lot a lot of people are so
obsessed with new when
so much of business growth and back to
the small businesses on here
because small businesses are so obsessed
with the new
one of the reasons i was able to build
my dad's business in such a substantial
way was i was obsessed with keeping
everyone we got
yeah yeah and look so christmas just
passed or the holiday season
we took media dollars out of our media
budget and put it into holiday cards
we sent every single one of our
subscriber a stamped
envelope holiday card there was no sales
message
there was nothing in there just had some
light ryan creative in there
and people love let's talk let's talk
about what the ryan creative is because
a lot of people may not know reference
what that's all about
so uh in 2019 november of 2019
ryan reynolds bought met mobile so he is
now
one of our owners he's the the tour de
force on creative he's an
absolute just gem to work with
brilliant creative strategic guy and i'm
really excited we uh we may have some
content dropping later today
no okay oh nice i like that now i'm
hyped
he is he is a juggernaut of culture i
agree with that
um what about biggest learning about
media for you aaron
we're all learning i'm in this every day
i think i'm as good as
it gets i'm proud of my work and i'm
stunned how on a weekly basis i learned
a new little thing a new little thing
so we're all always learning anything
stand out
as a good learning for you during covet
because again like i mentioned earlier
for a lot of us leaders it was a year
where we could get a little bit deeper
so as you were going through that
anything stand out like i didn't realize
linkedin did this or wow podcasts do
that or
when i asked that question does anything
spark yeah and but it's not one singular
thing we've had
you know the very early days of the
pandemic were very difficult
i think everybody's business was
struggling but as we started to
emerge and you know the the fear left
but uncertainty was still there
we realized it was an opportunity to
stretch push and grow so we started
pushing for that and we launched a new
product uh the unlimited plan
we didn't have that before and it's
crazy because i think
this is gonna sound so blatantly obvious
but when you have a good consumer offer
and smart creative and you're not trying
to be too clever like just get it out
there
everything hit it once like everything
started working so our digital budget's
expanded
our tv budget's expanded we're doing
more like
classic direct mail that might be a big
shocker for most
people but we're doing more direct mail
than ever and it's performing
it's it's i mean people are stuck at
home and they're checking the mailbox
so direct mail has been a real killer
which was you buying direct mail play
differently
geographically uh financially
you know i did a lot of direct mail for
my dad's business and trying to give
some education to people thinking about
direct mail
you know for certain things higher
income levels for certain things much
lower income levels uh you know
mile radius awareness overlays like how
detailed into that direct media do you
see
yeah so we've got a really interesting
program where we don't use your
traditional vendors like a valve pack or
velasis or any of those what we've done
is we've went with a company who
centered themselves on creating direct
consumer partnerships so
the brands that we're next to in this
mailer are the
caspers warby's dollar shaves hymns
and the piece is premium like like it
looks good
it's got good quality paper oversized
envelope it doesn't
feel like junk mail so that helps the
open rates for them and then
let's it's less junky mail yes exactly
nope
classy not ashy keep going nah and that
that's been a hell of a one for us and i
think you know the other thing people
need to realize is they have
tools in their systems they just haven't
discovered yet like we're a wireless
provider
you know we just we realized as long as
we're providing a
service update to the customer we have
access to do something most brands don't
we can leave a voicemail on their inbox
right
so we can do that that's something that
is unique to us
and we do it now so we have big big news
coming
we've had big news in the past and we'll
let ryan record a voicemail or he wants
to record a voicemail i should say
letting the customers know hey your
service just got better
and that's a media vehicle unique to us
but i challenge the people watching to
really look at their business and
understand
if they're handing out paper receipts
can you do something special there
this personalization customization is
key man
and you got to be able to do that and i
think if you're really looking out for
the customer
your message is going to be received for
example
we are actively right now we launched
unlimited but the reality is you don't
need it most people just don't need it
so we're actively telling people hey
you're probably overpaying us
right it's better for you to trade down
and save even more money
now that's a sort of a terrible business
decision if you're looking at short-term
revenue
it's a fantastic proposition for
long-term business health and
we use our own platforms for that to do
the customer right and i think if you're
doing your media
and your message that way that's a
customer solid it's just going to
perform better
i appreciate that um
when you when you think about media
because we're siloing it out here
how do you think about the contextual
creative
for those pipes do you feel the
conversations advancing
um to a place where those two
disciplines
need to be far closer because we've gone
through this great era
of really siloed executions on the
infrastructure and
marketing landscape and in individual
companies as as the internet
grabs up more you know it's a very
fascinating thing to see those
disciplines come
back together in the corporate world it
obviously stays together
in the mid and smb world thoughts on
that you mean creative and media
together
yes yeah so we don't we don't execute
plans of just media like our
marketing is baked into what we do the
creative
is way upstream right we're we're laying
out a general
strategy for the year with product
releases service enhancements and that
etc
but we're bacon marking into this this
idea of unlimited
right like where you don't need
unlimited we're gonna trade you down
was an insight that was built at product
creation
we knew we had this marketing built into
it so we put that into the plan
ryan dropped a video about unlimited
what people didn't know was there was an
easter egg
so we went back you know a couple months
later and said hey you guys miss this
by the way we're going to tell you you
can save money and that message
is all over our media so we're not
really even selling unlimited at the
time we're selling the idea that
we have unlimited but you don't need it
so come to us real quick i apologize
throw up because we have one minute i
want to give
dr this question he keeps texting and
it's a good question
aaron is there something you would
consider of value in another telecom
company that mint is currently
struggling to implement
or for that matter is considering
a value of another telecom i'd say no
like we are quite frankly these guys are
they're bad
this is bad business like you don't hear
people say i
love my wireless provider it's like a
like an airline man
like we're trying to do the opposite of
what those guys are doing i
look i'm envious they have massive
customer bases and gigantic budgets but
we're not that brand
and we're going to keep doing the
opposite of what they're doing
they're running these games we're doing
the opposite we're going to be straight
and consumer-centric
cheers brother have a great 2021. good
to see you
dara tressiter joins us next as svp
head of global marketing and
communications at peloton the world's
largest interactive fitness platform
she oversees brand institute strategic
marketing
consumer insights and strategy
communications and creative to build the
pelton brand
growth and international expansion a vet
c-suite marketer dara was previously at
carbon
ge apple and goldman sachs
welcome adora thank you so much so glad
to be here good to see you gary
came to you it's so good to see you i
mean this will be a lot of fun i mean
you're sitting on
as hot of a brand as there is which i'm
sure has its own
you know challenges you know high class
problems in comparison to others
um a just for four seconds before we go
into the direct question
what an incredible time for this brand
you know obviously
nobody's excited about a global pandemic
and there's so much pain
but we're just going to put this into
business terms the product was so built
for the moment that must have been crazy
yeah you know i think i give so much
credit to our incredible founder john
foley he knew
uh a truth which more people have come
to see
which is you can get an enjoyable
energetic
effective workout from the comfort of
your home with a connected fitness
product
but when he came up with that idea it
was novel right and you've seen how the
category has grown and expanded
thanks to his leadership and peloton's
leadership so you know i think the
pandemic has
accelerated the the trend but this is a
permanent shift this is a permanent
shift that people
are now enjoying you know exercising
connecting
um with with friends and family from the
comfort of their home
using a connected fitness product
when you think about media planning this
year you know it's obviously a
uh an interesting time for this brand in
an opportunistic time
any is there anything that's made the
cut this year that wasn't part of 2020s
planned which was a reaction
to the insights that you garnered from
2020
yeah i think that you know i would say
they're sort of two big things i think
one is the relationship between creative
and media
i think more than ever before that
connection is so critical
right it's so important that early up
when we're thinking about
the marketing strategy and the plan that
creative and media
involved up front um and are actually
working together to determine what makes
the most sense
because i think gone are the days where
you know a creative might just come up
with an idea
you know in a silo and media does kind
of the media planning
and just the creative hands off over the
assets that's not the reality
you you are aware because i know your
pedigree that that
is the far majority of the behavior of
the fortune 500 landscape
and it and and i think that's what i'm
saying is that that shouldn't be
so i think you're if you're you're kind
of hungry
if you're you know what you hope to be a
modern marketing organization you really
can't operate that way
um and and that's what you know i'm
really excited about the work that we've
done together
as a team at peloton and i say we right
because it's really you know
working together with my amazing
teammates is come together and
and updated our campaign process so that
that connection and
partnership between creative and media
is happening so it's so so much more
seamlessly
that is enabling us to i think really
perform better
and and deliver work that pushes the
brand and the business forward
so i think that's just something that's
so critical and so important
and i know it's not kind of the
traditional way our industry has run you
kind of have
media folks and creative folks and i
think that integration is so critical
and so important
not only and then i apologize and not
only that as you know
it's also top down in boardrooms
subjective calls push it down matching
luggage on the internet
versus what happens when you integrate
creative and media together in these
lower and mid funnels which branding is
now being done
and you're able to actually use it as a
consumer insights driver
to funnel up instead of matching yeah
it's a
i mean dar i don't think most people
understand how upside down the whole
thing is
it i i agree with you and i think that
this when you're right
in your career did you first have the
taste i i'm gonna i mean this one's
probably quite progressive compared to
knowing your rolodex
was it near where you were like oh [ __ ]
this is much deeper than i realized or
was it somewhere along the line
it was actually probably the first time
i became a cmo when i had the ability
right to like
change um that i realized oh
it doesn't have to have i don't need to
do it the way it's always been done
this can be better and and then trying
it out and seeing the result
inspired me so now i've kind of carried
that with me in all of my
sort of you know um all the other roles
i've been in but it was the first time
when i had the opportunity
to be in leadership where i realized i
can make a change and guess what
this is so much better um and so and i
think it's just it's really important
that we
we we see that you know as marketers
and that we bring that to our
organization what do you tell your
fellow fortune 500 cmos
that you know that know that you're
further down that path when they hit you
up like what's your advice to them
knowing
that the troubles they have with their
holding company relationships or their
board or their internal mmm or like
how do you how do you consult them on
bringing that to a reality
honestly i tell them the success stories
right
because i think many times people you
know are moved
even though i mean i'm a creative
storyteller but also data driven
people are moved by data then they're
moved by stories
so having being able to say well here's
an example of what we did here's how it
worked
um i think that that kind of inspires
them to be able to go back to their
teams
and i always say why don't you try it
you don't have to start it with
everything try it with a few
projects so you have some strong you
know proof
points that you can then use to sort of
especially for those that are maybe are
working where
they have such large teams it would take
a substantial you know reorganization
um a recalibration um changing culture
right to drive but i honestly believe
that that is the future
of marketing um i think that is the way
that we need to operate as an
organization how do you
one of the key things you know one of
our key values of peloton is empower
teams of smart creatives
how do you do that if you don't have the
the and i and i
when we say the creatives we don't only
mean people who work in creative
right even in media you're there's a lot
of media innovation and media creativity
how can we empower our teams if we don't
bring them together
to be able to think concrete and what
about and what about
something we call post-creative
strategists right who's doing the
qualitative
read-through on the work exactly
because you know the the math shows one
story but the 17
000 comments across all that content in
a month
has incredible consumer insight exactly
is that a big part of your world is that
it's a huge part it's a big part so you
know i've got
the consumer strategy and insights team
as well and so when we look at our
current campaign process you know we
have
our media team our creative team working
with
the consumer strategy and insights team
working together as
one right whether it's with the brand
marketer or the product marketer kind of
leading that effort
in order to bring about the best work
and i think it's that
you know connection uh between all these
teams working together not just you know
i ship something to you you go do this
but being included up front i think even
in the in the
ideation sessions in the strategic
sessions i think allows each of these
experts to be better at what they do
i understand audio for two i got two
minutes i can speak to you for two hours
two minutes on audio is it a part of
your mix
how are you thinking about it you know
you start to see the emergence of things
like clubhouse
you know we've got an incredibly
emerging interesting thing with spotify
ads
podcasting thoughts on audio i think
audio is is important right i think the
power of voice is important and we
actually i think
experience that as a brand in a very
strong way because
you know our instructors are speaking
and they're unscripted
right and they're just they're so
there's some of the most intelligent
talented
inspiring people you've ever met and
they're speaking from their experience
from their story
so audio i think plays an interesting
role because it's it's living within our
product
but even in our marketing you know um it
also sort of lives within that space as
well
and that when i think about some of the
the offerings we have on our platform
like
outdoor running right that's really
audio that's the instructor speaking to
you
so i think the way we think about audios
as opposed to it just sitting
outside as just this one thing we think
about how do we incorporate this into
the different expressions of the peloton
brand
and how do we use that to continue to
cultivate
um you know and build connection within
our community with our members
this was riveting i appreciate you i
wish you continued success i really mean
it
thank you so much gary it was so great
to be to be on here with you
really like oh yeah thanks for all
you're doing for the industry it's
always great to kind of get your
insights and
and wisdom and just really excited to be
here you're very sweet thank you
next we welcome steve lesnard global vp
and product
of product and marketing at north face
steve is an industry vet with more than
20 years of experience in driving growth
leading global brand campaigns and
launching revolutionary
products and partnerships across sports
technology and lifestyle
previously steve spent two decades at
nike
welcome steve who's steve you're on you
brother
no worries you would think that i would
know by now
you know happy new year happy new year
you're on mute is an
is a required thing said at least four
times a day
i also i also want to i also want to
apologize in advance
i'm distracted by the tchotchkes and
collectibles
i kind of just want to come to your
house and garage sale the wall but
i'm a collector i like it i like it
steve
um apparel that's a fun you know
so much going on in your world again
probably one of the sneakier you know we
hear a lot about the airline and hotel
industry we hear a lot about local
restaurants
i think people are not talking as much
around the clothing and apparel industry
which has
clearly been affected by covid um
talk to me about how you go into media
planning because that's the theme for
today
in this new year are there some
different things you're doing as a
reaction to the realities of business
uh you know the lower funnel conversion
on dot com for
awareness um give me some 4-1-1 give me
a kick off to how you think about 2021
media planning
yeah i think i think you know i think
what aaron and dara said was uh was very
relevant i think for for
us it all it always starts with
understanding our consumer better
uh you know we're in you know we equip
you know i was just talking to actually
some of our athletes
we equip some of the best athletes to go
on the far corners of the world
but really we also you know equip a lot
of consumers who just want to enjoy the
outdoors
and what we've seen during the pandemic
is a real surge
for people to actually spend time
outside because that's the only thing we
do
and so for us what we find really you
know powerful
is if we know if we can identify the
need of our consumer based on where
they're at
in their journey i'm you know i'm
planning a hiking trip
i'm planning a camping trip if we can
actually
you know show up in their feed when it
matters most with the right information
uh that has proven to be quite
transformational for us we've seen a
massive hike of camping
of hiking believe it or not even snow
sports
people have you know like wanted to you
know spend some time outside
and so the idea of better understanding
our consumer base where they are in
their journey so that we can show up
you know uh you know in the right way is
a big a big pivot
that we're doing for us so when we think
about media
i mean you said it like the media
approach has been like
our industry very big idea driven
you know you know upper funnel media and
we're really completely changing that
the way we like to think about it is
it's it's everything
is mobile first because in any consumer
journey and we have gearhead we have
people who really want to understand the
product they're either going to buy
and you know for the activities they
have so we we want to make sure that uh
through a mobile first approach we can
provide the right info
at the right time in their journey uh
that's that's the big approach and i
have to say
it's really interesting because it's
forcing us to think very differently of
thinking about the medium the channel
you know as you know as early as when
you create concepts and create it
100 i mean to me that is like
that's like oxygen to not think about
distribution
and the context of this you know there's
television print you just knew the size
of it and then you put the idea in
the amount of products features platform
slang differences between a tick tock
and a linkedin and
which your brain could play amazing in
both you know
is really remarkable well i'll tell you
what it's interesting too is it also
triggers
some really good conversation for us
with our team around
the need for speed and agility to
reunite
and then and how do you get there you
know what are the right partners that
can think that way
and casting of your team right exactly
and how do you set it up internally as
well so that you can
you can do it the right way i think it's
a i think it is going to be a
massive shift you know in in the way
brands you know work with partners and
agencies to really
cater to that need the partners that
won't be able to adapt
will force brands to create these in you
know internet in the house
you know yeah steve i got to ask you an
extremely important question
how many times a day when kovit's not
real you know in real life how many
times a day do people say that you look
like clark kent
because what's going on in the comments
right now is completely unbearable
and i need to know on average is it 3.6
is it 5.9 is it 13.
on average how much clark kent do you
get in a week a day
never you know never heard that but i
i'm becoming blind i have to wear this
to see you guys oh so you've never
gotten but now you're just
adding you know what's in the beginning
of the journey of the clark kent i like
that that's funny thank you
your brand is very revered there's a
secondary market for your products
you know in in this contemporariness and
need for speed
you know it makes a lot of sense right
like to me
that must be the big anxious moment that
you're thinking through like how do you
get that there because the brand
doing that perfectly is going to really
succeed because it has so much equity in
it
um have you started dabbling into
aggressive influencer
tick-tock are you thinking about how to
integrate since there's no ad product
into something even as progressive as
clubhouse
how good do you feel about your
cutting-edge marketing right now
i would say we've got a long way to go
the the great thing is we have a team
that is you know solely dedicated to
thinking about it
in that way um we like to also um
we're learning where our consumer base
is consuming information because what
we're finding out is climbers
snowboarders
trail runners they consume information
differently in different channels
so we're trying to you know to uh to be
a lot more savvy and the best way to
present information
in the right channels i would say gary
we're just starting the the fun thing
about the norse faces
we're an outdoor technical brand we made
some of the best product
you know for the most extreme conditions
uh you know i literally i was talking to
uh jimmy chin you know right before
talking about the next project that he
has with some of our athletes which is
only
mind blowing but at the same time
you know we just launched a partnership
with gucci you know like celebrating
celebrating you know like our very first
catalog in 70s so
we know the ability to understand who
you're talking to which audience you're
connecting with
is really like uh going to be critical
for us
you know to be relevant and authentic
moving forward and so is gucci
is you know that to me seems like a one
plus one equals three
do both parties come to the table in
that scenario and feel that the
crossover brings them equity
into some spots that they may have less
and just becomes a beautiful
you know uh integration that was the
idea you know like when we talked to you
know when we connected with the team the
thinking was
celebrating you know our heritage in the
70s in the outdoors and you know
alessandro the creative director
is fond of you know that era yeah you
know of the 70s so
literally a lot of the creative that you
see even the music soundtrack
you know comes from you know the you
know the the band that was rehearsing
next to our very first store
in this is that right yeah like all the
people see are actually really drafted
from our very first catalog so
it's celebrating the outdoor but also
bringing a new point of view a fresh
point of view
uh you know to access to the outdoor so
so that's that's
that's one element but obviously for us
right now we're about to launch a brand
new innovation
around you know trail running and light
hiking and understanding how you serve
ultra trail runners who run 100 mile
races uh
has has reddit hit your radar i mean
there's so much community there has that
been i mean i know that's more
progressive again this is
always where my brain goes right like
what an opportunity you're talking like
reddit has incredible uh opportunities
of community and has a
has a underpriced ad product in the
scheme of things because people don't
think it it's obviously a
tricky community and you have to be
quite authentic has that been brought up
yes we we have we're actually looking at
this
right now you know you guys will see
we're going to make some uh
we're have some partnership with all
trail and we're also going to be working
with
strava to go after that ultra trail
running community we're really
we're a brand that you know speaks to
micro communities who are really into
the craft of what they do the gear that
they use
for the endeavors that they pursue and
uh
and the idea of being really connected
to
these communities is really important
for us and frankly that's what we do
even the specialty channel it's been
heard quite a bit you know with kovid
but it still plays a massive role for us
because if you're a gear head
you know you will go to these you know
channels because you know this
the staff knows you know knows you know
what you know what the problem is
i want to sneak this in with one minute
to go so i apologize has the e-commerce
capabilities of the internal team and
understanding exploded because of covid
like there was
you must be so advanced by comparison
yeah we we've grown we matured a lot in
the last year
you know that's just the way to go
anyway you know i love it listen i
really appreciate your time
i wish you a lot of success thank you
thank you talk to you soon
talk to you soon next we welcome angela
zapata
cmo for hyundai motor america angela
joined hyundai with more than 25 years
of experience
on the agency side she's responsible for
all of hyundai's marketing
including the strategic direction brand
advertising
experiential marketing digital and
social media brand partnerships
and lead generation welcome angela
good morning thank you hey gary how you
doing
good first of all your purple turtleneck
is fierce you came in
hot ah well it's still early in the
morning here ish
you know so anyway might as well come in
bright it's a bright sunny day here in
southern california
let's go right into it because i think
the uh the car industry fascinates me
um when you think about media planning
in 2021
what is a in your mind a winner or maybe
even a loser of allocation of dollars
something that
you are seeing more opportunity and or
less opportunity like when you scan that
landscape
where's the opportunities oh there's so
many opportunities
um great um you know we're still a
challenger brand or that's still how we
see ourselves i mean some people have a
hard time even
knowing how to say hyundai we just make
it easy hyundai like sunday
um but you know we need to be everywhere
our audience is
so you know winners and losers you know
some people pick on traditional media a
little bit
and yet it still provides some of the
biggest platforms and the biggest places
where our audience is
um but we have a lot of investment in
trying new platforms um because we're
trying to really get
in front of younger customers into our
brand
we're a very different company today we
now have a full lineup of suvs we have
incredible
tech safety on the cars that's not the
hyundai
that came here 35 years ago that
generation knows a different hyundai
that was a value driven car
this is now a much better vehicle that
really is
i'm sorry to interrupt is that hard to
shed that value play for a lot of people
like for the people that are
watching right now like when you come in
in that way even though it's 35 years
ago
it let's call what it is they did a
great job at that that caught a lot of
people's attention and did extremely
well
is explain to everybody how big or or
maybe it's not
of a challenge that is it is a big
challenge because
when you ask people what we're known for
they'll say great value
um but you know we want to get past that
and do what we call the the driveway
test which if someone comes home with a
new toyota
no one questions why you got a new
toyota in your driveway we want to be
that same brand as hyundai
and we're that kind of brand now we have
that same level of quality
and technology and safety as our
japanese competitors
we just need to let people know that
that hyundai that maybe you know we had
a couple of missteps in the past
um where we didn't always have quality
at the forefront but
it's an incredible company with a ton of
resilience and so the vehicles we have
today are very different i think that's
really great about
bringing millennials especially into our
brand today
because they don't know that brand they
just see what hyundai they see now today
and it's a fresh perspective so we do
see younger and actually wealthier
customers coming into our brand for the
very first time so we're excited about
that we still want to
you know keep our older audiences with
us but um we want to bring in a whole
new
you know audience moving forward how
much you know i'm sorry because you
really rocked me
on that hyundai like sunday how how much
or how little
have has the brain like i almost feel
like if i had the luxury of having your
job
like you know especially with football
with religion like like i
i don't know like i just watched a ton
of people overreact to that like who
knew or what
you know i think you know that most
people say hyundai right
right they try to they try to koreanize
it yep
yeah like has that been like in a world
now of fragmentation
it seems like there's a huge opportunity
for you to really own that i almost feel
like
one incredible year of bombardment in
social
especially doing wild stuff on sundays
52 weeks in a year
we could be in 2022 and all of us know
that
honda hyundai is saying yeah
yeah you know that was one reason why
um jose munoz is our ceo for north
america and ceo
he wanted me to come over from the
agency to then lead a cmo at hyundai
because
i have all this experience in brand
building building our brand
is our number one initiative we had many
years of being very focused on lower
final demand generation
demand generating tactics which was
great because we needed to just sort of
intercept where customers were shopping
but now people are starting to recognize
our products and they
you know we're bringing them in as a
fresh customer that
needs to understand us more and
understand more of what this product is
just more than the price and so building
this brand is really important you know
we are
very heavy and like sunday night
football we've never used the word
hyundai like sunday externally
um but maybe if it has resonance with
people maybe there's a big idea that
just just got generated on this
uh live well there you go live this is
how it works people but
um you know we are gonna do a lot more
brand building we're trying to bring
more of a face to hyundai sometimes we
feel like it is a little facelift
a faceless uh we have an amazing
chairman ias chung
he's a pretty young guy he just took
over about two years ago he's amazing
he's got quite a vision for the company
and so we're figuring that out right now
this will be our big breakout year we
have a lot of launches but the brand
needs to come forward um and we do have
some big ideas on how to do that but i
do like our hyundai
hyundai like sunday maybe there is
something there so
i think that in today's marketing world
with the amount of opportunity
with the internet structure i think i
you know to your point earlier about tv
you know i i think it's not only the
challenge and the debate of what the
consumption versus the cost are against
the grp's but it's also
when you're in a tv mindset people feel
like it's an
or game we're going to position a brand
this way or this way or this way or this
way
in my brain there is clearly hyundai
like sunday like legs but it doesn't
need to be the entire brand positioning
but it could be a monster
on surprise and delight on something
that's right and to me
that's the shedding it's kind of like
loosen that up
i don't have to have the same brand
voice everywhere i am
and and people and normal people
watching right now angel they don't know
they don't understand the concept of
brand voice like this is
it goes into a corporate ecosystem
conversation that
people like nobody's gonna be ticked off
if they see
hyundai like sunday on instagram and
facebook and tick tock but then on tv
they say
hyundai getting you to where you need to
go to they're not like oh my god
this is like nobody's appalled by that
yet the fortune 500 madison avenue
ecosystem thinks they are they don't
want to
check luggage when it comes to corporate
brand strategy it is true and
we do fight against that a little bit
too so
you're inspiring me to break out from
all of that and it is a constant
struggle there's a lot of people who
weigh
in to what we do um you know if you
stick stay to the creativity and really
talking like a human
to other humans then i think you would
realize that you don't
talk the same way to everybody that
you're talking to of course that's not
how we are as people so why should your
brand be like that too
so this is this is good for me i have to
have these moments to speak to people on
the outside to get me to thinking
fresh for the future oh see you're
wearing purple too you
you i was literally about to say i'm
such an
idiot look at this we're like so
matching now all right let's talk about
audio
because i i think um people are in their
cars
so there's like i i love audio
advertising for
automotive on podcast which is eating up
an incredible amount of consumption of
audio in car
yeah because i always think like oh
you're pissed at your car right now it
doesn't smell as good as it used to it
something just happened like you just
looked out the window and were envious
it feels incredibly exciting to me
huge yeah we we uh we've
we dip and well actually we love radio
we use it a lot
um for drive time uh we used to we call
terrestrial radio
we're we're moving into areas like
spotify which we did
um a a sponsorship or partnership with
them the last
this last year to launch our elantra
where we did a podcast there was video
two
partnered with inoscope artists and it
was called on um
unlock my city and basically they were
driving around their city talking about
the things that they love
so it was a podcast but then we did do a
couple that were video
just to help show more of the sheet
metal because that's what cars are all
about
but it's still great content to draw
audiences in
and we know vid audio is so big with you
know very loyal audiences that love to
plug in and listen
um and with the pandemic this was a huge
it took a huge spike so that spotify was
the first time we stepped in with them
we loved it it was hugely successful
we'll do more of that
we we love the idea of podcasts and just
radio
and audio in general anything you're
kind of taking a
scrutiny with you know like just like
maybe rethinking
that you know you've been in the game
for a while you know it's not about
razzing
print or facebook or snapchat or direct
mail
it's just i think i want to educate on
these shows is there anything that you
are saying yourself you know
i'll tell you a big one that was a big
decision for us was
we are not going to be in super bowl
this year and we were in for 13 years
so um i've been a super bowl for 13
years and never debated the
hyundai sunday thing when the biggest
thing in the world isn't on a sunday
i know well i'm pissed now i'll see you
later i'm upset
you know sometimes it takes a genius
go ahead
it was a huge decision it was because
it's a lot of money we still love it
we're still very tied to football
but you know for one day which we had an
incredible spot last year our smartpak
we got a lot of play on that we still
love it but you know we need to extend
i think a big super bowl day for many
more days um so it kind of spikes on
that one day and then it kind of trails
off
we need to kind of expand that a little
bit and so we're excited about what's
going to come this year but that was
a major decision for us because we've
been so tied to it
a lot of people were surprised um you
know it felt a little good to loosen it
up a little bit we feel like
so much pressure to have like an
award-winning course
every year but that still needs to come
through
with the creative it can't be any less
than a big super bowl idea
well listen we've got to run but i got
more stuff we'll we'll purple it up
another time go
forward up it was great to see you see
you continue
next up john rulin is the leading
authority in maximizing customer loyalty
through radical generosity he is the
founder and
author of giftology a system of using
generosity to build relationships
with new clients and generate thousands
of referrals
through empathy and kindness he works
hand in hand with organizations from ubs
to the chicago cubs welcome john
hey gary how are you good john my best
friend brandon warnock is going to be
thrilled when he re-watches this because
he is a big cubs fan so
thanks for helping out there john
actually i think you know unlike most of
the brands that have been on here give
us
the one minute spiel on exactly what you
do because i think that will help people
and then
what i'd like to think about is the
framework of gifting and what the media
platforms are that give it
some power to be able to do some stuff
yeah yeah so
i grew up in ohio i'm a farm boy goat
milk and farm kid from ohio and
uh i thought i was going to go be a
doctor to get out of dodge i grew up in
the town of 400 people but
uh i had a mentor uh early on i was 20
he was radically generous and built
these amazing relationships and was kind
of a referral machine
and i realized that uh yet you know in
any business
it's all about relationships whether
you're one person or a you know
10 000 person company everything rises
and falls on employee and client
relationships and so
i realized nobody was teaching people
how to be generous and to do it
strategically
most people would you know here's an
amazon gift card here's a bottle of wine
here's a whatever
and so i dropped out of med school and
started an agency
and about five years ago wrote a book
called giftology we're the only one in
the space everybody else sends
stuff but we're teaching people how to
use
gratitude and generosity and empathy
really as a
year-round thoughtful thing to do not
just to check the box at the christmas
time
uh like a lot of thank you go figure
yeah
um the channels you know like
what should brands or startups or um
you know entrepreneurs here be thinking
about what should they know about
which media outlets give them a better
chance to execute
the thesis yeah well i think that uh
our we're getting a lot of inbound of
people reaching out wanting to
engage we're talking about influencer
marketing and different things and
um i think a lot of people you know they
do things very generic and very vanilla
whether they're launching a book and
sending out
you know 500 copies and vanilla
envelopes or whether they're
you know uh trying to get on podcasts or
whatever else and so i think that
the focus for us has been going into and
i heard somebody else
mention this earlier on it's human to
human it's one to one
and i think that a lot of people have
done too much stuff that's to the masses
and i think that you know 2020 with a
pandemic i think people have realized
that hey
these are human beings that you're
dealing with and i think that a lot of
people
haven't realized until now until
everybody's at home and kids are running
in and dogs and whatever else that like
oh my gosh they're a human being outside
of
whatever channel they're in so i i'm
seeing a lot more people reaching out
and wanting to
uh you know like the the traditional
ways of building relationships whether
that's with mass media or whether that's
at conferences or dinners
like the traditional ways have been
blown up and so people are struggling
how do i build connections from afar i
think a lot of people took for granted
like i'm i'm going to be able to go to
ces or
the super bowl or whatever else all of
those building relationship
or engaging people is completely gone so
uh we're seeing a lot more people that
are doubling down on how can i
take you know my top two percent or my
top one percent
and similar to what you did with i think
you're talking about taylor swift
she can't show up at every wedding but
she can show up at one wedding
and you did it with the jersey uh you
know a guy
spends 300 on wine or
champagne or whatever and you show up
with a jersey that becomes a ripple
effect that's
that you know people are it's a story
worth talking about
whether it's on snapchat or instagram
and you're seeing brands
that are getting wise to leverage and
say hey i can't maybe not go to do it
for everybody
but let's pick 10 people and go all in
on those people i mean
and you know this i mean after crush it
which looks smarter and smarter these
days
the next book i wanted to write was the
thank you economy i wrote that in 2010
you know i mean i believe in this
it's in my religion i don't even
understand
how people i can't believe that p people
are
oh 20 21 like we should do how this is
progressive thinking in 2021 makes me
want to rip my eyeballs out and jump out
this window
me too i mean i've been talking about
for 20 years in a different vein than
you have on social media it's more like
you know if a relationship matters how
you show up for them in the valley
especially in a pandemic
is the time to double down on generosity
it's the time to show up and be extra
bold with people
john do you read that i apologize do you
agree a lot of people
[ __ ] this up because they want the
tactic for their business and so because
their intent
is grounded in that it kind of smeared
like
i think the reason this is such a
challenging concept is that you have to
have this
incredible kind of like separation of
the short term and the long term i think
what works for me john
is i do all this kind of stuff all day
long because i think in 67 year terms
and when people try to replicate it and
i watch them or when clients
[ __ ] up the stuff that i want them to do
it's because they care about the 67
minutes
or days not the 67 years thoughts
yeah i i tell people all the time the
long game is decades not days
and if you do it do something nice for
somebody and then ask for the referral
or ask for the the opening door
or do whatever that's not a gift that's
a manipulation that's a bait and switch
and so people people can tell i tell
people the time like
if you have the wrong energy when you're
doing something for somebody
then even reading between the lines you
can tell when somebody does something or
they do almost go too far
and then when it like you can tell that
you're being bribed like there's a
difference between being thoughtful and
yeah
gary i'm going to do you a huge favor
i'm going to pick you up at the airport
and take you to your hotel
but that's grounded in hey i need to
pitch you my business bro
so like you know they're like i'm going
to help you buy the jets if you give me
a million dollars to start this company
p you know and then the biggest one john
i don't know if this ever crossed
how this crosses over in your world this
gets into a very deep feeling i have
around people who say i always get
walked all over and i talk to a lot of
these people and i say
are you getting walked all over or were
you giving as a manipulation tack
because giving is giving on the other
person's terms
not on yours and i see a lot of people
crying gary i don't like being nice i've
always walked all over and i i'm a weird
guy i go deep with them
you know and i do this 20 50 times a
year and 99
of the time they weren't being sweet
they were trying to manipulate a
situation by giving somebody something
they didn't want
because they wanted something in return
thoughts yeah well it's like the book
give and take
there's giving taking matching most
people are matchers that want to
they want to be a giver but they're
playing in the matching world of like
tit for tat i do this for you then now
you have to do this for me
and i think you've talked about it like
your jab jab jab right hook was
you give give give give then you earn
the right to maybe ask but it doesn't
it does not give you the like like if
you keep score and get pissed off and i
tell people all the time like
i'll do things that like we sent
somebody a sauna as a gift
i didn't ask for anything and it didn't
pay off for literally years later
but it wasn't because i asked for
anything he was inspired and i think
there's a difference between and i think
that's where most people
get with gifting they're not really
doing gifts what they're doing
is they're it's a carrot and stick it's
a incentive it's a reward
and when whether it's for your spouse or
whether it's your biggest client or
whether it's for an
influencer when you do things with the
right intention
no strings attached and then show up
again and then show up again and then
show up again
you start building the social bank
accounts like with your spouse if you
show up
with a gift and then ask for something
five minutes later it wasn't a gift you
were trying to get something
it was a ticket it was a cost of
mentoring john it's exactly right
john i swear to god you're talking you
know what fires me up
i do a ton of this [ __ ] i'm more excited
when it doesn't pay out
it makes for a better story but you know
this because
you know i don't even i just love it
because it speaks to the merit of the
truth of the intent
well if it worked every single time then
it wouldn't really be like we're
emotional beings and what people don't
understand and
that's why agencies are a big company
sometimes have a hard time with like
playing the long game of you're going to
love on all these relationships and then
not ask for anything
and they're like what's the date on that
and i'm like well it could pay off this
way or it could pay off 10 years from
now
are you are you say you're playing the
long game but are you really willing to
make deposits
your year after year quarter after court
and your employees clients suppliers and
the answer is most of them
they they want to say that they're
playing the game in decades but really
they're playing it in quarters because
they're a publicly traded company
and they're like i got if i do if i go
take my marketing budget
and i slice off five million dollars and
go invest in all these people and it
doesn't work
then my head rolls and i'm out of a job
and so most people are positioning
themselves
to play the safe thing and leveraging
generosity with all these relationships
is a weird concept and it's a freaky one
but it but if everybody was really good
at thoughtful gift-giving it wouldn't
work it would just be nice
it's the least weird the least you know
this is the most human
be a [ __ ] good person funny [ __ ]
happens
go figure i don't know all right brother
thanks for being on continued success
hey thanks for having me
up next we have marissa freeman the
chief brand officer of hewlett-packard
enterprise
marissa helped lead the historical split
of hp into two separate entities
today marissa leads hpe's experience
marketing team
driving brand strategy global events
sponsorships
advertising media and digital marketing
welcome marissa
thank you thanks for having me hi gary
hey maurice how are you
good being a good person man that's good
go figure right
go figure it's what my mother always
said
brilliant let's talk about media plan
you know actually why don't you
quantify because hp comes in a lot of
forms so i want everybody to have
good context talk to me about hpe so
people understand and then i'll go into
the combo
thank you so hp hewlett packard is what
everyone
thought it was forever and then five
years ago we split into two companies
one was the printers and pcs and that
went one way and that's the blue logo
and then the other one became the data
cloud
5g ai edge computing company and that's
where i went
i i find it to be incredibly exciting
you know
it's not really about edge cloud it's
about
data companies using data to make
people's lives better doing cool things
and making experiences better for the
rest of us so
and so you're targeting more b to b we
target p to p so
yeah you know there's about seven
defined that p to p
people to people human to human um
there's like 17 people in the buying
decision process but they're all human
beings and
and they have passions and likes and
wants and dreams just like the rest of
us
and so i think about
media strategy um in telling human
stories
and and connecting with someone with the
things that they care about
but for the audience's uh uh value who
are the decision makers normally in an
organization that buy your services
what are their titles and what are some
what are the services sure
so it starts it we actually have to
approach the c-suite
because these are huge tickets right
millions of dollars in investments
some not not all of them but most you
know we work with every
major global company on the planet and
they spend a lot of money on i.t
so it's the ceo this
very primarily the cio and cto
and the chief digital officer and
increasingly the chief marketing officer
because data
is the new oil right it's the currency
that we all deal in
and so uh the c-suite really important
to us and then we have a layer
underneath that
of i.t decision makers these are the the
guys and gals who are
data scientists and they they're doing
the coding and they're
specifying you know what cloud companies
you work with and what
what workloads go where and so they're
the ones who actually
have a very big influence on the
decision so we got the whole spectrum
there
when companies and this is going to help
a lot of small and large b2b companies
b2b companies and i'm sorry p2p
companies but
when when you're selling to a company
that's spending over a million dollars
and sometimes 10 million like big
ticket items to your point
how do you and and and by nature
those companies tend to skew more as
sales driven companies than brand
driven and marketing driven companies
because there's
a lot of you know need for sales people
there's a lot of conflict
in that game because brand is hard to
fully put your hands on an roi
sally closing an 8 million deal can
speak to that
but how much did the brand have it's a
really fun puzzle
yeah and relationships are critical
right period right period
today's world influencing to create
consideration build awareness
of this c-suite is that the linkedin's
in a world where conferences used to be
such a big play for companies like this
and they're not going on with covid
print print advertising in the b2b
magazines that have the attention
of the c-suite give us the lay of the
land of how you're thinking from a
marketing now on a p2p standpoint
well about 70 of
all of the research i'm learning about
any big ticket item
like this is done online it's done with
friends and it's done
through word of mouth and it's done
through search so
we spent a ton of time softening the
market and building confidence and trust
before our sales folks even get a phone
call or or make the phone call
um yes events went dark this year we had
last year nine weeks to turn our
biggest event 12 000 people showing up
in las vegas with cios
and their staff into a virtual event
nine weeks and uh it was it was insane
but we did it and it was
really good and we will never go back to
a hundred percent in person without a
digital
component attached to it we love our
in-person event it's amazing for us
but the power of data and digital when
applied
to that relationship and then carried
through the year it's just
priceless any platforms
that really have your attention going
into 2021
uh in terms of the events or media
platforms media platforms
yes um i
wanted to have this conversation about
passion points you know
so for example we we work with mercedes
formula one
okay disney studios disney parks
um tottenham football club the warriors
and chase
stadium so when when we tell the
technology stories underneath all of
that
like how does lewis hamilton shave
milliseconds off of
off of a turn that's a data story right
um so for me platforms media
plans kind of have to write themselves
based on the creative story and the soul
of the story so this is interesting
you're saying
that when you think about media plans
and creative intertwined which i love
you're actually looking at the current
landscape of your clients
and using the interest graph
of your client's passion point so you're
saying wow
we have the warriors one of the more
progressive organizations
so we're gonna we're gonna use the
reality that they use
us because a cio who's in linkedin or
print or an event who happens to be a
basketball fan is gonna stop in our
tracks more around that and then see the
underlying story
than us talking about milliseconds yes
using your own customer's ip that's
really
great it's wonderful and it and it pays
back in dividends because
the custom the people people reading
linkedin scrolling through linkedin
they also have netflix over here or the
basketball game on in
in the background and that's who we are
competing with gary like everyone's home
so i'm sorry real quick there's
something brewing everybody on facebook
it seems like some
scammer is trying to say you want a 20
000 picture or something like that
for the record because there's
cryptocurrency you will never hear from
me or my team there's millions of fake
accounts of me
i'm never giving away free money or free
cryptocurrency like
you should know that by now i know it
might be enticing for a second but
please don't ever fall for that keep
going
i had to do a public service
announcement reading no it's a good
thing
gary is a major risk and a very big
passion point by the way fair enough
it's one that we just it's a scroll
stopper especially for cios like you or
ceos
for sure um i'm sorry please keep going
yeah so we
we so the formula one for example or
basketball you know we will build our
whole plan
around the intersection of people who
make
technology decisions and love basketball
and you know we can buy media like that
and we can buy search like that
and that gives us seven times the
engagement rates
gary seven times and that's on you know
an average day seven times let's uh let
me do something different for the last
two minutes to mix up the show
you marissa the human you
what what ads or what platforms are
converting you have you bought something
for your home or clothes or food on an
instagram feed ad
have you yeah of course yeah talk to me
about you what's capturing what's
catching your attention
well i love newsletters i'm big on
morning brew and things like that i i
met the guy from morning brew his name
was joe a couple of years ago and
i started following it and i bought it
for my company
we have been we were one of the first
advertisers in morning brew
i love axios we buy axios i'm a podcast
fanatic
i personally just absolutely love yours
i love many podcasts i walk my dog and i
listen to a podcast
we have super computing um with we
bought cray the biggest best most
amazing super computing company in the
world
and governments buy that stuff so we
went on niche podcasts
hacks on top mike murphy you know like
axel david axelrod
i like that i like it are you are you
getting live
reads or you or is it um i try to do the
howard stern thing where
i'll get i know mike so i'll say mike
here's the script because i know you
want to do your
thing read it you know say whatever you
want and and he knows about this stuff
he's so smart and then
occasionally he'll go off script which
is what you really want right of course
yes so by the way that's a perfect way
to end this occasionally going off
script is exactly what you want
we need more marketing take care of
yourself we'll talk soon
next up we have frank cooper iii the cmo
of blackrock a third frank leads
blackrock's marketing across
every region of the world combining the
science of data and tech
with the art of creativity culture and
purpose
frank began his career as an
entertainment lawyer later serving as a
top exec
at two of the world's most iconic music
labels motown and def jam
he later went on to c-suite roles at
buzzfeed and pepsico
welcome frank oh frank you're on you
brother
i'm still learning man still learning
great to be here
thank you great to see you for everybody
who pepsico was a very early client and
frank was a superstar
and this is a huge joy for me and we've
built a friendship through the years
frank thank you for being here
great to be here gary great to see you
frank uh as you go into 2021
you know you've you've you've done
exactly i've watched from afar you've
done what i
what i thought you would you you there's
a contemporary energy
brewing at blackrock that i really felt
between your music and entertainment and
the rockstar status at
pepsi and then you go to buzzfeed like
you've had the kind of career that if i
wasn't an entrepreneur
i feel like i would have your type of
like it makes sense to me right it's
it's it's like in between corporate and
entrepreneurship
um you know as with that energy in mind
how are you thinking about your media
plan in 2021 where are you looking to
get creative
what are some of the things that are
emerging for such an iconic brand
yeah yeah yeah gary thanks look and i
i've learned a lot
um through you over the years and and
honestly uh uh
more 101 uh and just having
conversations so i appreciate that
but look i mean the way the way i think
about it is taking one huge step back
is i first think about the context of
the times in which we live
and um you know a great media plan in
times of stability
will fail miserably in times of what if
if it's rigid if it's written if it's
written by the way i'm sorry to disrupt
you everybody that was a huge insight
because again what frank just did
subconsciously matters
the big companies are incredibly rigid
compared to the mid
small and entrepreneurs they lock in
frank comes from a pepsico world where
they locked in their tv
and i was 80 percent of the monies and
like when something happens you can't
get out of your fox money or you're
super
right frank that's exactly right and and
and look if you think about the times
we're in right now
the massive shifts they're they're the
shifts are happening across social
they're happening across cultural
landscapes they're happening in the
technological sphere
uh they're happening in the political
sphere it's changing everything
fundamentally and what we what i think
we're facing is uncertainty
and large companies do not like
uncertainty
large companies are used to managing
risk
and they're used to incremental change
but i just embrace the times that we
live in the times that we live in
is a time of fundamental change and
accelerating change
and the antidote to that is creativity
the antidote to that is you have to take
some leaps you have to take some
some risk uh in moving forward so i come
in
when i think first about a media plan i
come in with that particular mindset
you know that we are going to take leaps
uh we're gonna leave
some flexibility within the media plan
so that we can adapt
as things will inevitably change so for
me that's kind of the first step
i take you know the second thing
here and and frank were you able to
create more flexibility
up front budget this year than you did
last year like did you go into this year
with
less locked in 100 100 yeah
good for you and look at this you know
this i'm starting to interrupt again i'm
just excited
you know people talk about things but
don't get around to it because of the
corporate culture and just
easier to do the same old thing so to
hear that you buy math
have less locked in to give you the
mobility
now i actually think that's very
practical it could make sense but
it almost you know people talk about
it'll never go back to the same world
postcode i feel the flexibility you feel
this year
even though the world's back to normal
and should be stabilized
the the nectar of that flexibility is
going to be intoxicating and will become
more of the reality
a hundred percent look and i don't think
there is a a a
thing of going back to normal i actually
think what we experienced in this past
year
just kind of accelerated and amplified
what was already happening right beneath
the surface
and and beneath the surface is that it
is a time of rapid change
and but look it look i was able to do it
but not all in one fell
swoop i was able to spend time as money
um by
talking first to you know those in the
c-suite
other senior executives about what's
real and what's not
um avoiding the myth of impressions you
know um you know not getting
mesmerized by uh um kind of the
the sizzle of a video yeah and talking
to them about what really matters
so so that that made a big difference
but for us you know we're we're in this
world where
um you know pepsico i think my budget
was at least
11 times the amount that i have here
do you think that forces you to be
scrappier do you think when you know
it's kind of
when i think about the world it's hard
to be hungry when you're fed
do you think that restriction has caused
and that friction
because you're accustomed to a different
budget world do you think that created
a more innovative uh gear inside of you
and your team
there's no there's no doubt it made me
and the team more innovative uh you know
it reminded me of the uh early days of
hip-hop actually yeah when when you you
know you just have to have the hustle
spirit
you figure you figure out how do i make
things work
given what i have and and one of the one
of the
most i think foundational shifts we made
was that we we realized that the
messenger is a message
and so we tapped in we tried to and
we're continuing to try to tap into
you know influencers but not necessarily
the big cultural
influencers those people who have power
to shift the thinking and behavior of
the people that we care about the most
and you're taught your target which will
be a totally different influencer than
if you're palatine
100 and what i love about it is that now
you know we used to do it purely by
relationships and
and kind of a kind of a cultural feel
you know of who's in the marketplace
and we still apply some of that but now
it's heavily data-driven
and we can actually see um and
visualize who is having the greatest
impact on the topics that we care about
the most and so so when i think about
media
i think first and foremost about the
times we're in but then i shift to
so what can we deliver to the people
that we want to share
with others because that's where the
message really resonates particularly in
this time where people don't really
trust
large institutions they don't trust
corporate voices
they trust people who are in their
immediate network and um and so we try
to feed that immediate network
with information graphics uh
um you know background material of
quotes things that they can share
and and for me there's a lot of power in
that
i agree frank what what about um
you as a consumer i enjoyed that last
question what what's grabbing your
attention from a marketing standpoint
like
give me an anecdotal story like i need
to buy a stereo set this ott ad happened
or i just bought
this new running shoes on instagram and
that surprised me i'd never done that
before
you got anything that's happened over
the last couple months well you know
look for for me for me personally
um like if i'm at home and uh the thing
that has
shocked me is the extent to which i'm
buying off instagram
um you know i'm buying things i probably
don't even need you know
and i see like you know some you know
work at home pants and then you know i
click it on
and and you know it's like do i really
need it but it just feels good and so
uh i'm purchasing a lot off of instagram
but the the platform
i'm absolutely obsessed with i'm totally
obsessed
with linkedin and uh i'm obsessed with
it um
more from a professional perspective but
just overall it is
relationship driven it is focused um
it is is is not based on the the math of
large numbers necessarily
um it's based on on the groups that you
can get together around
one person one person and and i i love
it i love the fact that um you know
linkedin live is up and running
um i'm totally obsessed with that uh as
a platform
not only for leadership have you jumped
into clubhouse yet
yeah i have i have you know i'm still
trying to figure clubhouse out though
are you listening are you mainly
listening at this point or have you
contributed
i'm totally listening frank you have so
much to say
i'm pushing you as a friend go
contribute to one room you need to taste
all sides of it to really figure it out
right figuring it out is like figuring
out
oysters by looking at it or talking
about it the real way to figure out
oysters
is by slurping it you you need to jump
in and taste it
all right i'm going to tell you why
because i think for your sector
hosting some of those rooms for
blackrock will end up becoming something
real
in the next 18 months i'm going to
circle back to you gary i'm jumping in
this weekend
and i'll tell you how it goes honestly
i'm going to jump in i'm going to hold
you to that frank thanks for being on
the show
yeah absolutely good to see you all
right andrew i want to take the floor
for two minutes if you don't mind
please but st hang with me um everybody
thank you for tuning in i wanted to take
two minutes
uh and just say thank you uh the purpose
of
this entire programming and make sure
you sign up go to vaynermedia.com
there's you know uh there is on
vaynermedia on vaynerx.com right andrea
on vaynerx.com
yeah we also are on we also are now at
marketingforthenow.vaynerx.com
okay that's a mouthful on vaynerx.com
though there's a click for marketing
from now that we'll send them there
right
vaynerx.com yeah so go to vaynerx.com
at make sure you're signed up for uh the
announcements of the future shows but i
just want to let everybody know the
intent of this
you know two hours in the middle a day
for me is not the easiest thing in the
world especially at the
volume that andrea and i are doing this
show i know that my community is
extremely
vast and goes in many different places i
have a very big part of my life in
corporate
and fortune 500 land but i'm trying to
move the conversations and navigate
where there's some insights
i hope the passive nature of audio you
can even have this in the background and
the tab while you're working on
something else
i'm obsessed with value driving these
are kind of conferences that used to
cost a lot of money for tickets based on
the pedigree of the speakers that we're
bringing to the table and i hope that
you know andrew's got an extensive team
we're putting a lot of economics behind
trying to build and bring some of the
best marketing information in the world
obviously i'm spending a lot of time
personally putting out more smb and
entrepreneurial conversation
there's just one other tool in our
toolbelt and i hope you enjoy it i hope
it brings you value
and i hope inspires some kids to get
into this industry or
or more importantly somebody gleams one
little idea that a big company's doing
and figures out how to translate it into
theirs and then obviously all the texts
and emails i'm getting right now from
the corporate world that says
don't listen to the entrepreneurs this
is what we need we don't have much of
this thank you for the
the kind words and i hope everybody has
a great great healthy happy
wonderful thoughtful 2021. andrea thanks
for that gary and yeah we'd love to hear
from all of you
send us a note at marketingforthenow at
vaynerx.com
we've got another show coming up
february 25th
from 12 to 2 p.m eastern and it's gonna
focus on
influencer marketing so please join us
hashtag marketing for the now keep the
conversation going
and check us out check out all our past
episodes
on for joining vaynerx.com hi everyone
hit me up on twitter with feedback